Donald Trump is signing an executive
order to label Judaism a nationality and
we actually we talked about this on
yesterday's bonus show I wasn't planning
on talking about it on the broadcast
show but the amount of disinformation
misunderstanding and just plain old
idiocy around this makes me feel like it
probably warrants a little bit more
discussion today so trump's idea is that
in or at least that what he's claiming
is that it could be somebody else's idea
in order to fight anti-semitism on
college campuses you label Judaism and
Nationality that will trigger a clause
in the 1964 Civil Rights Act which
blocks federal funding from any schools
that allow discrimination on the basis
of nationality that's the idea but there
are many many issues here to talk about
one issue of course and it's not even
the subject for today but I find that
it's important to get on the record some
of what's called anti-semitism on
college campuses is anti-semitism some
of it is anti Israeli organizing by
people who are against Israeli foreign
policy to be clear there's both and
there is also stuff that's a combination
of the two that's not the real issue for
me here the real issue for me here is
that Judaism simply is not a nationality
and when you label it as such not only
is it inaccurate you're actually
perpetuating some anti-semitic tropes
about dual loyalty that is already the
source of so much discrimination and and
attacks on Jews in the United States so
let's go through this very carefully
because it's really important that
everybody understand the completely
misguided nature of this Judaism is
three things Judaism is a religion it's
an ethnicity to the extent that
ethnicity exists meaning I know if you
go back far enough we're all just Homo
sapiens but as ethnicity and race go
Judaism is an ethnicity and Judaism is
also a cultural group in fact it's more
than one you have Eastern European Jewry
which has sort of a different culture in
many ways than
Yemeni Jewry just as one example so I am
Jewish
ethnically we actually did DNA tests on
the show we had a DNA DNA expert come on
and analyze them my results came back I
am 100% Ashkenazi Jew this is a sort of
sub ethnic group of Judaism more broadly
I can't convert into that I can't
convert out of that that's an ethnicity
culturally I'm Jewish in that I was
raised in a Jewish family eating
traditional Jewish foods gathering with
family around Jewish holidays and I am
not religious one can choose to be
religious or not you can convert into
the religion of Judaism that won't make
you ethnicity
if someone discriminates against me for
being Jewish they are maybe
discriminating against my ethnicity they
may be discriminating against my
cultural group they might be
discriminating against my perceived
religion even though I'm not religious
but there's nothing in there about
country of origin in fact I was born in
Argentina
I'm now a citizen of the United States
so when you look at my US passport it's
an American passport I'm an American
citizen and it says I think I don't
remember if it's called nationality or
country of birth it actually might be
nationality on the US passport Argentina
I went to Israel one time for nine days
okay
period so at its core nothing about this
is about nationality now there are
people who are defending this decision
by Donald Trump in a mildly anti-semitic
way saying Judaism is inextricably tied
into Israel because that's where the
religion originates that's where
Christianity also originated you don't
see the same argument being made and as
nationality is defined in the United
States it does not fit but it's more
than just inaccurate when you label
Judaism and nationality it perpetuates
the anti-semitic trope of dual loyalty
Jews around the world and in the United
States have been dealing with this for a
very long time the idea is you're
American but you're Jewish so there's
some hidden loyalty to Israel or to
Jews over country or whatever such that
you're not really loyal to what's in the
best interests of the United States in
the way that an American Christian would
be loyal to the United States and this
is the source of some really really ugly
stuff so even if we take Trump at he's
at his word he is doing this to fight
anti-semitism this is still a terrible
idea
because aside from being factually
inaccurate it perpetuates this idea that
an american-born Jew who's never been to
Israel is not even religious if
discriminated against is being targeted
for their nationality think about how
boneheaded and simply incorrect that
presumption would be it's wrong it's
short-sighted it's problematic and
hopefully Donald Trump is going to be
talked out of this now as with all of
these executive order things that that
Donald Trump does this was unlikely to
really be Trump's idea this is something
that made no likelihood somebody came to
him with and said hey well how about
this what do you think about doing
something like this here's a good idea
here's why it would be good this is the
group that would be placated by it or
that group would be placated by it let's
do it
I don't even imagine for a second that
Donald Trump has any kind of deeper
serious understanding of what is
implicit or explicit in doing something
like this but regardless it's a bad idea
it shouldn't be done and it doesn't make
any sense I do want to hear from you
about this if you disagree if you think
this is logical let me know and try to
do it without perpetuating anti-semitic
tropes if possible right I mean just
with peace and love I'm suggesting that
to you today's program is made possible
in part by our sponser identity guard
giving my audience 33% off when you use
the link underneath this video we talk
about data breaches on the show we talk
about them too often because they happen
too often and a lot of people
underestimate how likely they are to
become victims of identity theft as a
result of these breaches that take place
and it's a nightmare the average
identity theft victim loses more than
1300 dollars and six months of their
life trying to clean the mess up it's no
joke but what identity guard does
is monitor the dark web and alert you
anytime your social security number
credit card numbers account numbers or
other personal information are detected
in places where criminals share this
stuff with each other online they also
detect red flags like changes to your
bank accounts or your credit scores and
you'll get an alert as quickly as in a
few seconds if you do become a victim of
identity theft identity guard sets you
up with a dedicated support team who
will take what would normally be a very
stressful situation and turn it into
something as easy as possible to resolve
and you'll be covered for up to a
million dollars of reimbursement for
stolen funds identity guard plans start
at just $8.99 a month but the David
Pakman show audience will instantly get
33% off by using the link underneath
this video you'll also get access to
identity guards browser extension which
protects you from phishing attempts
unsecured websites other types of
attacks just while you're browsing
around online it takes just a few
minutes to set up an account you give
them a few pieces of info about yourself
and you're good to go
the identity theft headaches are often
completely avoidable if you have a
service that's protecting you from it
and will help you to deal with it if
something were to happen an identity
guard is the most trusted one out there
it's already affordable but you'll save
an extra 33% when you use my link which
I've put in the description right
underneath this video